[Musique]
bienvenue dans le skyco le magazine qui
vous raconte les aventures économiques
du territoire de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines incubé au ski cube la start-up
check Tapei passe au crible vos
bulletins de salaire pour ne plus vous
faire avoir le centre de formation des
métiers du bâtiment le CFM BTP s'est
associé avec Lino Faria entreprise
spécialisée dans la peinture pour offrir
un cursus d'apprentissage à ses élèves
nuisant sonore qualité des routes
circulations routière
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et mobila
s'associent autour d'un partenariat le
but collecter et délivré de la data à
destination des communes pour améliorer
leur trafic routier
nous sommes au Technocentre Renault de
Guyancourt Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
mobile high sont signés un partenariat
sur la data à propos de l'état des
routes et puis de la pollution routière
pour en parler nous sommes avec la
directrice générale de Moby Life est
arrivé au bonjour hello good
existe depuis la renaultolution annoncé
en 2020
concrètement qu'est-ce qui se passe au
sein de mobylice qu'est-ce que c'est
mobile eyes
mode vidéo
search at the call of mobility
[Musique]
NRJ
date service
comment vous définissez the new mobility
house mobility
[Musique]
par exemple à quoi sert ce véhicule par
exemple
[Musique]
discussion
peut dire aujourd'hui que Moby days et
la marque de service de Renault
[Musique]
on collecte toutes les données des
véhicules connectés du groupe Renault
c'est donner là on les anonymise on les
sacrés on apporte l'intelligence et on
en extrait des cas d'usage qui
correspondent en fait aux besoins de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
Saint-Quentin Yvelines va devenir la
vitrine des cinq projets innovants de
mobilise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on prend aujourd'hui l'état de nos
chaussées c'est vrai qu'on doit faire en
sorte que nos habitants ils le font
remontent nos informations il y a des
plateformes que nous avons mais on a
aussi des services qui vont aller sur
les routes pour constater l'état de la
route dont vous avez des voitures qui
circulaient remontent ces informations
là en temps réel 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 forcément on est plus efficace et
avec un meilleur service public
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Eric dandel le directeur
du cfmbtp nous sommes centre de
formation d'apprentis et de stagiaires
donc sur l'ensemble des métiers de la
construction de bâtiments et travaux
publics du CAP au BTS
[Musique]
Vincent de molinis je suis chargé
d'affaires pour l'entreprise de peinture
linofaria situé à Élancourt
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis 1994
[Musique]
cette relation entre l'école de CFA et
l'entreprise c'est la base même de
l'apprentissage l'apprentissage c'est un
temps en école un temps d'entreprise le
jeûne apprend autant d'un côté que de
l'autre aujourd'hui nous avons 500
apprentis du CAP au BTS et donc en face
500 entreprises et 500 formateurs en
entreprise qu'on appelle les maîtres
d'apprentissage nous recevons les jeunes
environ deux semaines par mois pour
venir travailler chez nos clients sur
des chantiers intérieurs et extérieurs
pour des opérations de préparation et de
finition
l'intérêt du partenariat CFA entreprise
donc de l'apprentissage c'est que ça
permet aux jeunes à l'école d'apprendre
toute la théorie d'apprendre les normes
et en entreprise effectivement
d'apprendre le métier en situation
réelle pour nous l'intérêt c'est d'avoir
des jeunes qui soient prêts au monde de
l'entreprise dès la sortie de l'école et
l'obtention du diplôme
dans une période où nous recherchons
plus de 40 000 nouveaux compagnons dans
le domaine de la construction des
bâtiments des travaux publics le
partenariat apprentissage c'est-à-dire
le partenariat entre CFA et une
entreprise à vocation à se développer de
plus en plus l'idée la solution au
problème de l'emploi il est la solution
aux problèmes de la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée le partenariat débouche
souvent sur une embauche et quoi qu'il
arrive c'est toujours le jeûne qui
choisit la fin
[Musique]
le récit pour salle de tout compte c'est
quoi c'est un document qui va lister
l'ensemble des sommes qui te sont dus et
que ton employeur te règle au monde au
moment de ton départ je suis Awa Fofana
dirigeante de checkpape une start-up qui
aide les salariés à mieux comprendre
leur bulletin de salaire elle a été
créée en octobre 2022 et elle est
implantée à Élancourt
[Musique]
c'est une communauté de salariés qui
essaye de mieux comprendre leur bulletin
de salaire on est présent sur les
réseaux sociaux Instagram LinkedIn Tik
Tok et bien d'autres on est un peu plus
de 20000 aujourd'hui et l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'essayer de détecter les
erreurs de nos bulletins de salaires
pour ne pas se faire avoir
[Musique]
avec on va pouvoir être mis en relation
avec un expert paye indépendant qui va
pouvoir regarder le bulletin de salaire
et déterminer si oui ou non il y a une
erreur et nous donner les arguments pour
aller faire une réclamation éventuelle
auprès de notre employeur si il constate
une anomalie de l'autre côté on va aussi
pouvoir avoir des formations pour les
salariés pour leur apprendre à mieux
lire leurs bulletin de salaire puisqu'il
y a à l'école on nous apprend pas
comment marche une fiche de paie
[Musique]
alors moi ça fait plus de 12 ans que je
travaille en paie j'ai une expérience de
gestionnaire de paie et ensuite j'ai
évolué vers des postes de consultante et
de chef de projet à cirrh et pendant
toutes ces expériences je suis passé par
beaucoup d'entreprises et je me suis
rendu compte que de l'ouvrier jusqu'au
cadre supérieur personne ne comprend
rien à son bulletin de salaire et
parfois ça a des conséquences négatives
pour les salariés puisqu'ils peuvent
perdre de l'argent
[Musique]
on vient juste de démarrer avec
l'entreprise a été créée en octobre 2022
on a commencé les prestations et pour
l'instant je suis la seule gestionnaire
de paie à le proposer mais aujourd'hui
on essaye d'agrandir l'équipe de checker
de paye pour pouvoir être plus nombreux
à répondre en fait aux besoins des
salariés
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de créer un business model
qui fonctionne et qui est rentable j'ai
besoin aussi d'accompagnement pour
savoir comment recrute je suis junior
pour tous ces aspects là et donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai besoin de
l'accompagnement de ski cube pour
m'aider à faire cela aujourd'hui en
France si tu es salarié ton employeur se
substitue à ton comptable puisqu'il est
chargé de recouvrer tes cotisations et
de les reverser aux administrations
comme la retraite la sécurité sociale ou
encore le Pôle emploi et si ta confiance
a été mal placée si tu ne contrôle pas
tes bulletins de salaire il est possible
que tu te retrouves dans une situation
financière très délicate que ce soit
maintenant ou bien plus tard
[Musique]